would you invest in a startup that's
innovating in the metaverse so yes of
course i would um i think that
there's a 20 chance i would put it at
that
vr and ar become
a very significant big part of our lives
in the future
vr i'm not so sure about i think motion
sickness wearing the thing blocking out
the real world
you know it's gonna work for some
category of products really well like
educational or maybe casual gaming and
you know we heard about golf works
really well maybe snowboarding
beat saber there's like some physical
activity so i think education and
working out and those kind of activities
quite fun we'll see where it expands to
i think ar
could become you know like smartphones
an 80 or 90 adoption curve
where people put on ar glasses in the
real world and when you look at a
restaurant
if yelp is your default or zagat or
google local or whoever's glasses are
using apple it would tell you the hours
of operation this place closes in 21
minutes it might tell you the wait time
it might tell you the specials
you're walking down the street and if
somebody is opted in to being in your
network and is
a friend of a friend it might say
right above their head
uh good friends with your friend evan
and you could stop the person you say
hey and they see on yours good friends
with evan and it does like a little halo
like you both know somebody right pretty
interesting let's say there's a version
of tinder or bumble with ar glasses and
you go to an event
and it says hey this person's into you
know this person is looking for a
long-term relationship this person is
not looking for a long-term relationship
this person likes long walks in the
beach and yoga and this person likes you
know indie
music and kurosawa films whatever it is
there's going to be some interesting ar
applications that i think if you don't
use them you're going to be left out of
society much like not having a phone
today means you're left out of a lot of
functions in society think about it
15 years ago
you could go to a restaurant and not
have to have a smartphone today if you
go to a restaurant post pandemic no
smartphone or at the you know in the
endemic phase of the pandemic you go
take out your smartphone to pay and
order i mean i've been to some
restaurants where you know they're just
like that's the only way you can order
or you're driving and you need a map
like you're let's say your car doesn't
have navigation it's an old car you used
to have to pull over and ask at a gas
station for directions and write them
down remember those days you probably
don't watching the show half of you
don't remember those days but you used
to stop and ask for directions or
when you were on a road trip you would
get to a gas station and in the front of
the gas station they would have the maps
and if you were going east west north or
south they would have a row of maps for
people going north road maps people
going south and you'd buy that or before
you went you would go to a bookstore and
there was a map section and you would
buy the maps of the south we you know
alabama florida wherever you're going
and when you moved to la there was a
specific book that everybody would buy
and you
they would be on every but the floor
boards of everybody's car in la had
those because la was driving culture
right so
i think that's what ar is going to be in
20 years where if you don't have ar
glasses you're missing like half of
society just like people
who you know you're on your phone and
you want to go to the movies
how are you going to look up movie times
you're going to go you can't i don't
know can you still call on the phone and
get movie times that's how we did it in
the 80s
you they were like
my parents would look in the newspaper
at movie times i remember in 1980s who
were going to go see raiders the lost
ark or
you know superman my dad would open up
the newspaper then my dad would say hey
can you call on the phone so in the late
80s you'd call on the phone movie phone
you get the times then in the 90s you
would call on the phone and buy a ticket
on movie phone that took 10 minutes but
it was a lot better than going down and
buying the tickets so what you would do
in the 80s and 90s is if there was a hot
movie like raiders lost ark you would go
on a friday to buy tickets for saturday
or sunday you go on thursday
and uh that's how you bought tickets and
literally if you wanted to our sporting
game or bruce springsteen was playing
when bruce or billy joel would play
we would go to a ticketmaster which
should be at a record store so there
were record stores to buy the records
and in the back they'd have a
ticketmaster with a little computer
and you would see at five in the morning
a hundred people lined up to get in
there for bruce tickets they would let
us in at exactly 8 am
person behind the counter would run 10
sets of tickets give them to a scalper
brooklyn style
and then they would let people in at 805
and you would just try to get tickets
and the first person might get second
row fifth row and then the person in the
end would get like the blues
so yeah i would definitely invest in ar
specifically the problem is today you
know those ar glasses aren't even out
except for the hololens
and uh those are thousands of dollars
and for very specific applications so
you have to be very careful investing in
companies
for a platform that does not yet exist
vr exists some of those companies are
now surviving but the vr companies that
got invested in five to ten years ago
and oculus was first coming out
most of them went out of business now
most storms do go out of business but a
lot of them went out of business
because they never made it to a point
where you could make millions of dollars
off of selling apps and i think right
now
there are some people like beat sabers
and rec room that have a million users a
month if they have a hundred thousand of
them paying you know maybe they could
start to hit break even but it's still
early days see
you want to be early enough that you can
innovate
and take market share but you don't want
to be so early
that you run out of money before the
platform arrives and users are ready to
spend money great question
you